all right i i pulled up this uh story
from mediaite oh my it's going to be a
red wedding january 6 committee airs
clips of extremists calling for violence
after trump promised wild protest you
ready says during its hearing on tuesday
the committee first showed former
president donald trump's december 19th
2020 tweet calling on his supporters to
come to washington the day congress
would certify joe biden's electoral
victory be there will be wild the
committee then showed clips of fringe
pro-trump commentators including alex
jones and tim poole responding excitedly
to trump's call it also showed clips of
extremists calling for violence on
january 6. okay so they do separate alex
jones and me from being extremists i'm
surprised i assume they would have
called alex jones an extremist but they
call us fringe pro-trump commentators um
fringe
at the time of that we were the number
one political show on youtube with 120
million
uh views per month uh well i should say
it was around 100 and then with podcast
views
these leftists were making these charts
showing like all the right-wing channels
and then tim poole was like massively
above that
fringe
that's the only thing i take issue with
it's not fair people people are hitting
me up and they're like are you mad
they're calling you pro-trump and i'm
like i voted for the guy what do you
like
when they hate you it means you're doing
everything right this one's amazing uh
uh so here's the best part about this
article it says you know clips from
fringe pro trump commentators alex jones
and tim poole but it doesn't actually
quote either of us it quotes matt
bracken and salty cracker
and then you know a cracker again and
then it's like
they don't they can't show anything from
me because what i actually said was so
completely innocuous
and i have the clip for you all right
here
so
let me fix the audio
it always auto plays
i knew the audio so let me uh let me
there's alex jones and i just want to
show you the part where it shows me
talking
because uh some people
you know they swear and we're trying to
be family friendly but here you go
and now donald trump is calling on his
supporters to descend on washington dc
january 6th he is now that was that was
extremism if i've ever seen it and then
there's one more bit let me show you one
more one more bit i'm scared this could
be trump's last stand and it's a time
when he has specifically called on his
supporters to arrive in dc
that's it are you excited i can't tell
that there was like one other clip where
it's like
i read the headline i was like trump
promises a wild protest on dc on january
6th and they're trying to discredit you
it's not that you said anything bad they
want ev all the boomers who are watching
all ten of them to think that you're a
bad person
it's it's weird because
that that boomer demographic is it's
it's we we have tons of people who are
in that age bracket who watch the show
and who comment all the time but the
people who do watch that stuff they're
aging out of voting and being involved
in politics i don't understand why
they're chasing after the demographic
that's retiring and handing off the
world to the younger generation that's
all they have left it's the last ones
plugged in in their matrix of lies and
they're struggling maybe if we can just
convince these 10 people that they'll
tell their kids but also it's because
they're not handing it off to the
younger generation they're hanging on to
it they're holding on to the power as as
as tight as they can that's for as long
as they can i mean if you look at i mean
these are my my parents generation and
they still call us all kids you know
they don't they don't act like we're
capable human beings and maybe we're not
but they but we certainly are more than
their geriatric selves are going to be
and the only reason they call you fringe
is because they want to separate you
from mainstream they want you to be
fringe so they try and they try and
manifest that you are even though you
aren't you've been authored we have uh
yeah it's an othering process yeah we we
had a uh times square billboard for two
months i mean that's that's mainstream
that's fringe before the show we were
talking about the reconciliation if it's
even possible to reconcile going forward
and like if you think that things feel
fractured you know culturally and it's
like before we were all being lied to by
abc nbc cbs they were deciding what the
narrative was everyone had a unified
whether it was a lie or not vision now
it's fractured and uh
i don't know that they're they're
attempting to
to force the narrative but my favorite
thing about this is the people who are
tweeting at me and they're like you
better get your affairs in order tim
like oh it's it's coming i'm like bro
you sound just like the q anon people
who are like it's going to happen
they're going to arrest everybody
move those goalposts just keep moving
them q is right yeah i'm like 80 years
dude it's a clip of me reading a fox
news article there was it's a whole the
whole thing the whole january 16th is
like an attempt to to hold on to the
bowl this charred this flipping like
america's changed it's a different place
than it was 50 years ago or 40 years ago
there's the internet and individual
liberty of like individual journalism is
taken off now it's another realm but
they want to like really like smash it
out and just keep it because they think
that it's going to go haywire and it
will fall apart if they don't they might
be something to that i love that they're
doing this because it was 2020 it was
the riots that woke me up from my former
stoner slumber where i was like wait a
minute lighting things on fire and
smashing everything is not cool man and
i started getting mad and everyone's
like well clearly you're racist i'm like
i'm racist because i don't want to watch
people like be anarchists in the street
not even the cool ones you're like i
watched a video of two white women
vandalizing a black neighborhood like no
you're racist right black women were
pleading with the white auntie foot to
stop it's like no don't care we saw a
video of that over and over again that
kept happening i think a lot of people
are waking up because of this um bull
poopy
yeah i actually uh i was talking to a
couple people and there are some people
who
are intently watching uh the january 6
hearings who don't like trump but are
like post-liberal disaffected liberal
types they don't like trump they don't
want to vote for him but they hate the
establishment and what i'm they're
saying like okay that was it like when i
saw you on there i was like what
so so there were people who want to
believe that trump is really bad but who
know the show who have watched it and
actually pay attention and they're like
i'm out i've seen leftists on twitter
putting like hahahaha laughing being
like they included tim poole this is
such insane bs it is insane bs and jamie
raskin has this to hold on to he really
needs this to succeed he had very
difficult time the past couple of years
um his son i believe killed himself
horribly and after that i i feel like
jamie raskin is just totally off the
rails he needs this to succeed because
i i don't know how you face that
tragedy
he's on the committee he's the one who
played the clips yeah a bunch of people
have told me that i should sue for
defamation because the insinuation is
that these are people encouraging or
inciting that's not what raskin said
raskin said promoting wild protest
promoting is an opinion nebulous term
that doesn't mean anything
yeah i've been through this before these
people are smarmy and they know the
words they use and they use them on
purpose
so there was one outlet that claimed tim
poole pushed a conspiracy theory and do
you know what it really was it was me
debunking it but by doing a story on it
at all it was pushing that story out to
people so i reached out to a lawyer and
they were like oh but you did push it i
mean that's an opinion statement not a
fact statement and i was like are you
kidding and they were like the fact that
you told the story to people whether you
were in favor of it or not is still
pushing you will lose in court
essentially it's everything's turned
into tmz us weekly and untouched this is
what celebrities used to have to go
through with just gossip and bull crap
and now gossip and bull crap is our news
and people watch it and they believe it
like what looking at the national
enquirer like elvis had babies with
aliens it's it's seriously that's stupid
i i a friend message to me talking about
something about like the podcast and
how they like don't really get celebrity
news that much anymore and i was like
politics is pop culture it is it is so
we we like it's like team sports doesn't
even matter anymore team sports is just
red and blue democrat republican and so
the issue is
because of that mentality
i was talking to this journalist earlier
on twitter about the january 6 committee
and how it's all lies and this is a
person who's like a normie journalist
who is kind of like well you know maybe
so i went into ground.news and i
encourage everyone to do this go to the
blind spotter
and take any blue check journalist you
can find this is a great project for all
of you who want to help create the
database load in any blue check
journalists from nbc from uh the new
york times from cnn from msnbc and all
of them invariably show like an 80 to 90
percent left-wing bias
they usually only consume news from
left-wing sources so i started just
sending i'm like to take a look at this
take a look at this sending these people
and they're like whoa these are nbc
reporters and they only consume leftist
sources and then i'm like and here's ben
shapiro 50 50.
yeah i mean when i when i edit in the
morning when i'm like looking for
stories that we want to run
i listen to npr i read the washington
post i read the new york times i read
fox i read politico axios daily wire i
look at literally everything that's out
there and then i try and figure out like
what i think is interesting to talk
about that day but i mean i start the
day with you know jack posobix podcast
and npr and you know the new york times
the daily like this is what i listen to
every morning you're biased yeah i'm i'm
oh my gosh look at that i wasn't even on
there because i deactivated my twitter
that's great
wow i've never seen that before i've
never seen that either that's mostly
because look who i hang out with
you're a far right extremist i can't
believe i'm sitting next to you i don't
i don't know who wrote this this
software because i don't know who's
deciding what's left right in the center
there's uh uh it's ground news and i i
think they're actually pretty code open
what are they formed their their account
is suspicious but they're moderates
fully but
well these are just your influencers but
i think the reason it's 96 percent right
is because you probably just post post
millennial all the time oh i do post
post money okay right if you get rid of
the post millennial thing i wonder what
the number would be if you could filter
it that would be cool i pretty much just
post post yeah sometimes i make little
comments is new york post left or right
now center right they're sort of in the
middle okay so it used to be far left
everything's the right now
the left was like an excessive liberal
mag back in the 90s the new york post
yeah the post it was like it was almost
like the national enquirer interesting
oh yeah
kind of a i remember they were tabloidy
yeah msnbc was they took carlson
i've told people this and they don't
believe me and i'm like you don't
realize what life was like
you've had an interesting conversation
recently with uh with a the former
buzzfeed guy uh semaphore
there's this oh yeah ben smith yeah ben
smith and ben smith was trying to make
him out to be a racist and tucker
carlson was like i'm a hundred percent
mad at
white over-educated liberals that's who
i'm pissed about
you know thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there